o
[Aplausos]
termo inovação aberta foi criado pelo
professor da Universidade da Califórnia
reumatismo nos anos 2000 basicamente
inovação aberta é o uso intenso da
relação da empresa um outros entes do
mercado que podem ser status
universidades ou empregadores que tenham
contribuído de alguma maneira para
inovação ou para negócios na sempre
é mas se esse tema já vem desde os anos
90 2000 como é que ainda em 2021 existem
tantas grandes empresas com dificuldade
de acessar e ter os benefícios desse
modelo de atuação certamente tem muita
gente competente tanto em consultorias
como Universidade estudando esse assunto
e procurando soluções para como mudar a
mentalidade EA forma de atuar das
grandes Organizações e empresas mas
todas as ideias por já vi eu acredito
que a maioria delas vai acabar passando
por dois tentos
mudança do comportamento dos indivíduos
ou seja cada um de nós que fazemos parte
das organizações
e também pela própria mudança na
estratégia das empresas Ou seja forma
como as empresas se organizam e se
propõe a resolver o problema dos
clientes
e vamos começar pelo primeiro que é a
mudança do nosso comportamento e
infelizmente maior parte de nós Obedece
à risca a primeira lei de Newton
princípio da inércia ou seja gente
começa a fazer alguma coisa vê que dá
certo e continuar repetindo para sempre
aquele mesmo comportamento ou no caso
das empresas alterna pior no primeiro
dia que a gente entra na organização que
a gente entra na empresa um colega o
chefe nos diz como as coisas funcionam
como são naquela empresa a gente aceita
isso e acaba nunca mais questionando e
repetindo aqueles comportamentos
isso é fácil de se acostumar e acaba nos
levando para aquele conceito de zona de
conforto ou de acomodação ou como
qualquer outro tempo que você quer usar
é claro que os próprios sistemas de
governança e controles de nas grandes
empresas foram criados para dar maior
proteção aos acionistas da e reduzindo
incentivo a tomada de isso e ao
contrário do que algumas pessoas pensam
quanto maior o cargo maior
responsabilidade na organização maiores
são esses controles Então os executivos
acabam tendo muita dificuldade em
assumir riscos e fazer de fato mudanças
muito grandes Em alguns momentos nessas
organizações
se você tem um peso e claro que a parte
da explicação mas eu pessoalmente
acredito que a maior mudança e a maior
barreira a essa mudança na realidade vem
de nós mesmos
Esse é o tema do comportamento e da
necessidade da mudança de comportamento
e assim como no mundo da física para que
mudar a inércia tá saindo da inércia é
necessário que uma força atue de alguma
maneira nesse corpo no nosso caso eu
realmente acredito que essa mudança é
uma sensação de desconforto que tem que
vir de dentro tem que ter de nós mesmos
a e nesse ponto a Inovação aberta tem um
papel muito importante principalmente
nas organizações
tá pegando o nosso exemplo ela tomou
setor de telecomunicações quando a gente
passa a tua mais abertamente atuando
mais próximo das estátuas de outras
empresas que estão desenvolvendo novas
soluções ou trabalhando de maneiras
diferentes é quando a gente vê realmente
o tamanho do GAP e o quanto que nós
podemos mudar aqui dentro isso gera um
desconforto muito grande esse
desconforto nos força a mudança faz com
que a gente realmente busque maneiras
diferentes de atuar é muito importante
se conectar com quem está questionando
os estados todos os negócios e temos
muitos exemplos hoje no mercado
a loja tivemos exemplos de empresas que
viraram para ser os nossos que faziam
por exemplo modelos completamente
diferentes de processo de busca de
talentos recrutamento de pessoas na
nossa área de recursos humanos ou então
empresas que trabalham os inteligência
artificial para acelerar e otimizar o
processos processos jurídicos e de
defesa e é muito bom e muito importante
falar com quem está fazendo isso se você
ainda não fez surgiu de conversa com os
fumadores mas tá pago com quem trabalha
nessas empresas e tente entender
exatamente como eles encaram seu negócio
seus clientes a forma como pensaram no
propósito da empresa e até mesmo cometia
dos seus concorrentes
e talvez você se Surpreenda vendo que é
uma forma muito diferente de Como as
empresas tradicionais e Grandes Empresas
estão acostumados a pensar muitas vezes
um potencial concorrente vai acabar
virando um parceiro de negócio muitas
vezes para entregar a melhor solução
para um cliente você tem que abrir mão
talvez de parte da sua receita Mas cansa
no longo prazo essa talvez seja a melhor
resposta e esse tipo de mentalidade
muitas vezes entra em conflito com a
forma como a gente atua nas grandes
organizações nas grandes empresas e isso
é muito saudável mas para começar a
fazer essas perguntas e para ter essa
abertura isso requer um processo que
existe bastante humildade que às vezes
infelizmente falta nas grandes
organizações
e eu por exemplo setor de
telecomunicações
historicamente a nossa indústria
indústria se desenvolveu a partir de
conectividade começou com telefônico
algumas Décadas atrás e depois passou
para os dados e o nosso consumo de dados
inclusive o Tamarindo e vai parte
aumentando cada vez mais
mas em toda sua história o foco foi
sempre na conectividade
mas nossa usuários sabemos que por mais
importante relevante que seja tanto a
conectividade a qualidade dela ou a
quantidade totalmente seu pacote de
dados ele é um meio para que a gente
enderece alguma outra necessidade nossa
pode ser consumido algum conteúdo para
streaming de música ou de vídeo fazer
uma consulta por telemedicina ou estudar
como tem acontecido bastante durante a
pandemia
e por isso alguns anos Já começamos uma
jornada de transformação
e a criar um ecossistema de negócios
baseado em negócios digitais que vai
além da coletividade estamos entrando em
áreas como entretenimento saúde educação
segurança e outras que vão complementar
à proposta de valor para os clientes que
Originalmente inocente olhavam uma
empresa de telecomunicações e que agora
vão ter a possibilidade de usar os o
fluir esses negócios todos a partir de
uma experiência digital comum e também
com benefícios a partir desse cruzamento
desse conhecimento que vai ser gerado
desses negócios interconectados e essa
mudança ela só é possível por causa da
Inovação aberta ou seja nós por
definição precisamos estar mais abertos
e em contato gerando negócios com
parceiros de é diferente seja tem
parceiros status como fornecedores como
sócios e novos negócios ou até mesmo
investindo em algumas dessas empresas
que em algum momento podem passar a
fazer parte desse ecossistema e dessa
plataforma digital de negócio e depois
de tantos anos já se fala de inovação
aberta já se pratica na vossa oferta em
muitas indústrias e muitos países
e talvez seja hora de todos nós
abraçaram os esse modelo e essa
mentalidade que o benefício vai servir
todo mundo uma das grandes mudanças e
talvez benefícios que inovação aberta
tem trazido ao longo dos últimos anos é
uma mentalidade e realmente de
compartilhamento de conhecimento
compartilhamento de competências e
habilidades que no final acaba sendo
positiva para todos não apenas para os
Estados mas também e principalmente na
minha visão para as grandes empresas é
hora das grandes empresas pararem se
relacionar somente entre elas e também
se abrirem mais para as pequenas e para
quem está começando
Oi e essa mudança
essa abertura no fundo ele depende de
cada um de nós
depende da gente sair daquela inércia
daquela acomodação e sentir um
desconforto entendeu o que que nos faz
mover o que que nos faz mudar e colocar
em prática agora
obrigado a
E aí